as chair of the house ways and means
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of covert 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically this is a revenue work
session
please note that there's no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporariously to
this meet
however in accordance with sea order
i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporariously during
this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaries listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available on the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar
on the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271 3600 or email
hcs
at lake.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us
christopher shay and brad greenland
i don't know if director anyone is here
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call of attendance when each member
states their presence please also state
whether there is anyone in the room
where you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
know law
the eruption of bernstein and we do have
a replacement today for representative
who is
represented
connie lane
if you take the
role
representative bernstein certainly will
thank you mr chair and good morning to
you
um
good morning lads and lassies today is
march 17th 2021
it's 9 03 a.m we'll begin roll call with
saint patrick abrami
[Laughter]
i'm here at my home alone
mary griffin
representative griffin
representative owery
that's o'leary
oh my
home my wife is in the house someplace
representative russ ober
coleman hudson with the six cats
representative fred ducette
good morning home alone and sale
your clerk is alan burstein i'm in my
home office in nottingham new hampshire
my wife is downstairs representative
elliott
here in salem new hampshire my wife is
in the house somewhere
representative john jeanigan
i'm home in my
office in salem and my wife is somewhere
in the house
representative herschel nunes
good morning mr clerk uh i'm home alone
in pelham new hampshire good morning
colleagues
representative tim baxter
good morning mr clerk i'm home alone
representative walter spillsbury
holmen charlestown a son and wife
elsewhere in the house
representative paul tudor
home in northwood alone
representative susan allmey
i'm alone in lebanon and we seem to have
a second norman major
let's see that
representative richard ames
i'm here
home alone
representative tom southworth
here alone in dover
representative dennis malloy
home alone in greenland
representative tom
schamberg in wilmette in my home office
my wife's in her home office
representative edith tucker
um alone in randolph
representative jenny del marlow
home alone and swansea
representative tom laughman
representative lofton
substituting for representative amanda
gourd is representative connie lane
i'm home uh in my home office in concord
and i have two family members in the
house
welcome to ways and means representative
lane
thank you
representative mary hacken phillips good
morning i come to you from my home in
hanover i have a couple of cleaning crew
members in throughout the house at the
moment so you might be hearing vacuuming
um otherwise alone thank you
good morning representative james murphy
a home alone in my uh home office in
hanover aaron go
bro our esteemed leader chairman norman
major
i'm home and my wife is in the house
mr chair there are 22 members present
two are absent
mr chairman on representative lockman
has told me that he has to take his
children to
daycare before he can start working each
day so he'll he's always going to be a
little late
when he shows up
okay so he'll be showing up today
and then tomorrow the replacement for
him
yes uh marjorie smith
first thing we're going to start off
with
this morning
i'm sorry
representative major representative
ducette has his hand up
yeah just briefly mr chair i spoke to
representative griffin she's uh she's
unable to join us today in totality so
just want to let you know
thank you representative
we're going to start off today
to look into the credit carry forward
issue
which is in
house bill 2
where they want to lim limit the credit
carry forward to 50
and that seems like it's going to make a
fair size hole in our revenues
and
so what we have done is we've invited
the
treasurer the comptroller and the dra to
discuss this issue with us
so uh
chris is
uh the controller
i know uh carolyn's here as the
controller and the treasurer here
yep they're all here dana and monica are
both um in the call now
welcome
so they should all be able to unmute and
talk to the committee as you ask them
questions
okay and moniker is the treasurer
that's correct yep presenting the the
comptroller
and caroline
is representing the ra
one of the issues that we have
monica is this
credit carry forward which has been
building up
or last year we had
up to better than 270 million dollars
is this a
standard procedure that other states
follow
or should that be in a separate fund
separate from the
general fund
and we don't know
where we're going to be
where it's in house bill 2
and they want to limit it to 50
of credit card forward of
taxes
and it causes a real problem
over the next few years
so if you
help us out on this we appreciate it
is it standard
good morning uh thank you mr chairman um
uh good morning members of the committee
for the record monica mizapelli uh state
treasurer uh and thank you for inviting
me
um i'm gonna start with um a little bit
of disclaimer i i have not had the
opportunity to um
um to discuss this topic with the array
so what i can um
so i i have um a little background
um i guess i will say a little bit of a
background on this issue
and and
so i was hoping today and i believe on
the comptroller is is on the call today
and and
and a person from dra so i was hoping as
part of this conversation to also
understand um you know the impact of of
this change
what i so so i what i can say is um
i am not familiar with what all the
states do
the um
if if the change that i'm reading um
you know the the sums the amounts are
significant
or are
large significantly large so that will
definitely you know a change like this
one uh could certainly impact our
liquidity um since we've been uh
utilizing this um
you know the they've been in our pool
cash all this time and as someone will
you know a change like this one
um it will be a significant change um on
how the state has been operating
and and again some of the numbers that
i've seen
what i would love to understand is uh
first of all i've been reading
a bit reading about the impact on
revenue what i have not had the
opportunity to discuss with tra is
is
how much of this is is actual cash
and so what i will need to understand is
the magnitude of the cash the true cash
impact
um
and how that will change the amount that
the state retains
and in also the timing of when
um
i guess well we go through this
transition from
um
from taxpayers choosing
how to handle the overpayment so if
that's going to change
i i will need to understand the time and
of when these funds are going to be
returned to taxpayers
and injured and during that transition
period um it would be important for us
to to know
um again how those funds will be
disbursed
in in
um
[Music]
if it's going to be on a monthly basis
if it's going to be right after
taxpayers file just details like that
our cash cycle is pretty consistent we
have um
we have a clear picture of what our cash
cycle looks like it really is based on
our budget and those are set most of
them are set payments we you know we
have the significant uh disbursements
are set in statute so
if if if you look at our cash uh year
year it's pretty consistent how we
um we have this um net inflows and and
and
how our cash
um
hard
cash flow um operates so
um
again with this um large amounts
just to change alone it would be
important for for for
obviously we will have to work with dra
really closely um to see how that's
going to work so so that's what i can
share with you and again um you know i
apologize for not having the background
i just have not had the opportunity to
to speak to dra about this
um i know there's some accounting
concerns too and so um again i i guess
as part of this um this discussion i i'm
hoping to also be educated
and hear from the controller and and
from dri about this issue
um and i'll be happy to ask answer any
questions if i can at this time
you did mention that
you're not sure if this is
all cash or not and i thought it was
it's
not it's all
to me it looks like it is all cash it's
cash that came in the door
the overpayment of taxes and our concern
is that
in 2017 it was like 172 million dollars
in 2018 196 million
in 2019
268 million
and we're standing in 20
271 million dollars
and if that's all cash then those are
very large amounts that uh certainly are
liquidity we'll feel it and and and
again so i think
um
we will have to really work really
closely with
with um department of revenue to
understand how those funds will be
um you know the sovereign payments will
be handled um so our liquidity is not
impacted
okay
maybe we could hear from dana the
comptroller
and dana is this a standard practice
to handle credit carry forward this way
and the other states doing this this way
is vayner there
she is but she's muted
so i don't know if she needs to unmute
herself
dar six
on mewtwo is that correct
yes if you're on a phone
okay there she is
she just unmuted
dana are you there
jenny
jennings
dana's still there
dana appears to be here and appears to
be unmuted but
we can't hear her
um
if she can hear us i would suggest
logging out and logging back in again
or calling back in again if that's
okay maybe um
in the meantime
we could hear from the dr the dra
on
what
to put the question to bed is that
is this money
all cash
carolyn maybe you could answer that
good morning representatives carolyn
lear assistant commissioner with the new
hampshire department of revenue
um if possible could we also promote
melissa rollins to a panelist if she
isn't already i just i'll very quickly
call on her to help out
um
so the money
that is reflected in our calculation of
ccos is all cash that has already been
received and deposited by the state
i think
um and monica king i'm sorry the
treasurer can correct me if i'm
incorrect
but i think the question was more how
would we expect that money to leave the
state
would it be the state
cutting checks or would it be reduced
future revenue
and i think the answer to that question
is both we don't really know how
taxpayer behavior will change
in anticipation of
new hampshire theoretically passing this
legislation
some taxpayers could reduce their
estimated payments in anticipation of
the change and then we would see this
reflected as
reduced revenue in the future
if taxpayers don't change their behavior
and they file their returns and reflect
a large cco on that return
we would then be issuing a refund and
that would be real
real money being cut as a check
um going to taxpayers and i think what's
a challenge about um predicting
which we're more likely to see is that
we're not aware of any state who has
done this before
so we're really just trying to predict
what taxpayer behavior will be
in response to this statutory change um
the physical impact analysis that you
have
received from us on this change
you arrange
that assumes both scenarios and i
stopped it there absolutely carolyn you
mentioned that you
don't know of any other states that have
done this before does that mean
um
return the
limit the credit carry forward
or not
have care credit carry forward
just give complete refunds
thank you for the question
representative we're not aware of any
state that has capped credit carry
forwards and required the taxpayer to
receive a refund okay
is dana
who of us now
good morning can you hear me
yes we can
oh great i'm so sorry i don't i don't
know what happened this is dana call for
the record
i've been at my desk in the office
trying to talk to you
um but
would you like me to jump in now or do
you want to continue with the r.a why
don't you jump in now
okay um
so i think what i wanted to mention is
that um
from an audit perspective this issue has
been discussed for many years
and
we here at das
specifically the comptroller's office
have
that worked with the ira to evaluate
this
what essentially is a liability to the
state
so when you have payments that come in
that are overpaid
we would
in theory
record a liability against that cash
that came in the door so if it's
expected that a future
refund is coming
and it relates to the current audit
period the auditors would expect us to
record a liability so it's not a matter
necessarily of putting the cash aside
and funding the liability in an escrow
account but it is expected that on the
from a kafir perspective the state's
audited financial statements there would
be some reflection of this future
liability and this issue has been
discussed at length
with the legislature and
management for years
what we have come to is that the
auditors have given us an audit finding
the last two years
it reflected in our audit financial
statements
essentially disagreeing with the state's
accounting position we have not recorded
this as a liability in the general fund
because it would be a direct hit to
general fund surplus it would reduce our
unrestricted revenue
and
prior
years
legislative leaders have not wanted us
to do this essentially they have agreed
with the state's accounting position
that we we feel that
cash
refunds paid is something we record
but we have not taken the leap to
necessarily record a hit to surplus per
se for this item
and much of that has been because
there's been a lot of analysis of when
that refund actually goes out the door
and what how long we hold on to
what they call it is
what the accounts refer to it as we hold
taxpayers money on account for them
essentially
for them to decide when they're going to
apply it to a return
or an estimated payment and so there's a
lot of analysis involved as to the
timing of what taxpayers typically
decide to do in that regard
so we balance that out with
so we wouldn't be asked to record a full
270 million dollar liability what we've
what we've determined based on dras
analysis of taxpayer activity is that we
would be looking at about a 60 million
dollar liability attributable to the
fiscal year at hand so the last two
years
we have elected to not record a 60
million dollar hit to surplus and the
auditors have what they call passed on
that adjustment meaning it wouldn't
change our general fund balance sheet to
the extent that it would make the
readers not be able to rely on our
state's financial statements so they
have allowed or agreed that we don't
necessarily need to book that liability
but they have had concerns and have
expressed that to the fiscal committee
the last two years in our audit so
it is a significant issue it's it isn't
the full liability because again there
are assumptions made as to when the
taxpayers will actually
use those credits up
um so there's an entire analysis that
gets done each year
but what it it if we did record the
liability um it would be included in our
gap adjustments that we make each year
to make the kefir
as part of our final audited kaffir and
it would directly reduce general fund
surplus
i can entertain any questions on that
aspect
to the questions
uh represent almighty first
followed by representing yours
thank you mr chairman i think that uh
representative brahmi had his hand up
with me before but anyway
i'd like
yeah i'd like
i
i think it sounds like uh
the comptroller knows more about this
language that's in hb2 than anybody else
on
and
i am confused
as to if we did this
does it require that someone who has
five million dollars in that credit
carry forward right now
on to
take
all
take back all
but
on
half of their current this year's
my on credit carry forward
on and
like about maybe 95
of that 5 million and take it back this
year
and if not why not how does the language
work
uh well i would just say this is dana
again i would say that i wasn't involved
in the drafting of house bill 2 so i
would defer to dra
if carolyn could weigh in on the
transition time but i think what i would
generally say about the language is it
is a
it would be in from an auditor
standpoint from our external auditors
kpmg it would be a step in the right
direction to limit our exposure from a
liability standpoint at some point they
may decide that they cannot sign off on
our current accounting policy um and and
cannot be comfortable with it
so this what this is one of the things
we've discussed uh is a sort of a step
in the right direction to
minimize the magnitude of this liability
um so in that sense
we would have to talk about as as you
mentioned representative almi like the
transition
and
whether it would be implemented over
time from a prospective standpoint that
i would defer to uh department of
revenue to weigh in on
yes
on we we need to talk to whoever created
this language
i think
and we need we need to figure out a
transition that works
thank you
the uh caroline could help us on that
carolyn you want to respond do you know
did you help them with this language
yes representative thank you the
department could help the governor's
office in drafting this language
um
the the change would be effective for
taxable periods ending
on or after december 31st 2022 so this
would be for tax year 2022 and to answer
your question representative almi
yes
in the spring of 2023 if a taxpayer is
reporting
a cco
their
return
and that cco exceeds 50
of their current year's liability they
will be sent a refund for the remainder
as this is drafted
could i ask a clarifying question just
to make sure
go ahead
if someone has had
five years of of on
money sitting with you
are they going to be required to take
back
four and a half years of that
thank you for the question
representative the answer to that
question is yes
and the reason
why is because
we when a cco was reported five years
ago
that cco has been used up to pay the
taxpayers liability
because we always operate on a first in
first out basis so we're always using
the taxpayers oldest money first
to satisfy their liability and it's the
new money
that
constitutes the cco
um
so
so there isn't a cco that's five years
old
[Music]
before we go to the next question
uh i just want to put this out on the
table
if the taxpayer
brought this money
back to themselves as a refund
and the taxpayer has
is paying taxes the federal government
they would pay 21 percent
taxes on this money every dollar that
they brought out
refunds
back to themselves
21 of that
is that a correct statement
because the federal tax rate now is 21
um your your correct representative that
if a taxpayer receives a refund the
state is going to issue them a 1099 and
generally although i'm sure there are
taxpayer specific
you know instances where this is not
true generally that will be includable
in income for that taxpayer
the reason being
that the taxpayer would have
deducted
that payment
um as a business expense in the year
that it was paid
so the taxpayer can
park their money with us
and not have to pay their federal taxes
and take it out when they want to
request a refund when they want to
i don't know if any of that is driving
this um
representative major may i interrupt for
a moment yes jimmy
uh
matthew melo is
has his hand up in the attendees
list
let me know when he's he's in
hello mr chairman can you hear me uh yes
we can
it is
the question that was raised
the author
of this amendment
will limit
the season to 50
could you tell us who that is
yes so this is language that did come
from the governor's office during our
phase of the budget
to address many of the concerns that
have been brought forward by this
committee both today and also
in previous work sessions
what i would say is our intent is to
lower the state's liability
that is held on our books in part
because of what
the comptroller has spoken to and also
what dra has mentioned
we ultimately want to get this to a spot
where the fiscal impact could be spread
out over a series of years
and i think that the committee is
already considering a couple of ways to
do that and in supplemental
conversations that our office has had
with dra
the 50 threshold
may be trying to solve the wrong problem
essentially to say that it appears that
the majority of the money that's been
accrued as credit carryover
liabilities for the state
are with businesses that are holding
either more than 100 percent or in some
cases more than 200 percent
of their annual liability
so there may be a way to resolve this
problem
at a much higher threshold
and still dramatically reduce the
current liability the state has on its
books
okay so then
rather than
limiting it to 50
if we went to 100 percent
uh
it would affect
the effect on the state would be
spread out over a longer period of time
as i was just saying
uh so the question is where do the bulk
of these dollars originate from
and our understanding when we first
wrote this language was that some
companies are paying
you know more than their
annual tax obligation for one reason or
another
the bulk of the money though is not with
the say small or mid-sized business
that's paying their next quarter or
their next two quarters it's with
companies that are for one reason or
another
paying
more than two or three times their total
obligation
and if we do want to reduce the
liabilities
you could probably set a higher
threshold either at say 200
of their liability
or 100 of their liability
and still reduce
a a high percentage of what those
outstanding current credit carryovers
are
if you wanted to phase it in you could
do a stepped approach
to say
over a period of three or five years
that maximum amount of their
annual tax liability that they can hold
maybe goes from 200 percent in year one
to 150 in year two
and then a hundred percent in year three
and then as taxpayers either modify
their behavior
or take refunds
that would spread out where the fiscal
impact
of this change
uh would hit the state if you will
and every threshold
takes about four years to phase in
so if you went 200
that would take four years
and then
the next year you go to
it would take
four years by itself or not so
is that
is that correct carolyn
carolyn
representative thank you the question is
is it true that it takes four years to
feel the impact
of
a change
yeah yes if they change the threshold to
and then maybe a year later
change it to
100 percent
you have a four year
threshold you have a four year
to take care of the 200 percent it would
happen
and then the 100 would take an
additional four years
but starting at year two
representative if you might indulge me
for a moment we've actually
mapped that change out
and if you would be interested in having
melissa rollins share her screen to you
she can actually
present that
chris could you
arrange
that um she should be able to share if
she can't just give a shout out
can you see my screen
we can
okay
great
for the record melissa rollins senior
financial analyst for the department of
revenue um
i'm going to focus on
this section representative major to you
to your question
you're correct um with the 50
cap
it is spread out if it's in one year
if it affects one tax year it is spread
out three to four tax years or three
excuse me three to four fiscal years um
based on taxpayers adjusting estimates
and returns
that can be seen
here this is the original impact in hb2
so this affects one tax year and you can
see the impact is from 22 to 25
depending on how taxpayers
adjust
their
estimates and refunds
just stay on that melissa just back up
so that the first year
would be
up to 30 million ahead
the second year could be from five to 86
million dollar hit
the third year 20 to 170 million dollar
head
and then the fourth year
up to 25 million and then almost nothing
that this year
that's the way i read that
yes yes that's correct okay
go ahead
so
um
following up with what
matt was speaking about we have done up
a couple additional options that are
different from what's in hb2 um and it's
addressing the 100
um cap on the liability and the 200 cap
on the liability that matt was also
speaking to
so in this first scenario um that you
see here
this is addressing that and this looks
at capping ccos at 200 percent of tax
liability in tax year 22
and then it's a phased in approach a
hundred percent of tax liability in tax
year 2023 returns and then 75 for tax
year 2024 and 50
in 2025 and you can see this
spreads out the impact um for
several years uh versus the previous
three to four years
we could stop there
and if you wanted to
come to a single number of the impact
then if you just divided it by two it
would be a six million dollar impact the
first year uh
about a 20 million dollar impact the
second year
and then probably a 40 million dollar
impact the third year
and the fourth year would be
probably about 30
close to 30 million dollar impact
and then the next year would be about
a 20 million dollar impact
and then the next year
dropped out to about
nine million dollar impact or ten
million times
and then almost nothing the fifth year
okay
yes i would only caution you on one area
with doing the middle average
we do know that the final reduction
based on tax year 18 liability would
need to be 137.3
so i don't think you can use the average
all the way down you'd have to
if you if you assumed that the average
would come in in the first couple of
years then you would need to assume
high end on the next few years to get to
a total of
137.3 million in the final fiscal year
okay
if that makes sense
go ahead
okay and then the next option that we do
have based on conversations that we had
in the previous committee meetings um
was looking at maybe not going all the
way down to the 50 now that we are aware
that there are taxpayers with the large
ccos exceeding the hundred percent and
on their uh tax return
is taking it to capping it at the bottom
of a hundred percent so this would be a
two-year phased-in approach
with 200 percent capping at 200 for tax
year
2022 and then capping it at 100 for tax
year 2023
and you can see
this the first couple of years are
similar
to the chart that we just went over
but then it doesn't drop as far
where the end of fiscal impact instead
of being
137.3 million would instead be 92.3
million
so
rather than
then we would be reducing our total
credit carry forward from
271 million 20 20
down to almost
170 million
is that about right
yes
uh representative brownlee
well i uh let's just have the uh dana
react to this chart
uh what i'm trying to understand my hand
was up for dana from before
but uh i think this is a possible
solution
uh and something we need to talk about
uh
you know picking one of these
but
so let's just say that
forget about these numbers for a moment
any number let's pick 125 million
that that
uh
let's say we pick an option that results
in 125 million dollars that has to and
we have to write checks back
to the
to the taxpayers
so on in the kafir
what would that look like that hundred
and twelve forty five million first off
it's a cash issue because we have to
write checks
back to the taxpayers 125 million we
have to pay back and this is maybe this
is a treasurer question as well
but so if we have to do that
what would that look like on the kafir
how would that appear i mean to me it's
it's an additional expense
to the state
that wasn't budgeted
unless we do decide to budget for this
uh but uh can you explain how that would
all work from an accounting standpoint
dana
yes thank you for the question i do
believe the so the revenue focus that
you're accustomed to reviewing is our
unrestricted revenue reported net of
refunds
so it's important to understand what the
numbers you're seeing have already um
any tax refunds that have been issued
are already netted out of those numbers
um
that's the easiest way to explain it so
this would be
similar which obviously
spreading it out would be much better
because it won't
you know be an alarming difference
but we do have
various um
levels in our in our tax receipts each
year and obviously 18 and 19 i just want
to remind was a very high year so
um getting back to the
the level of this overpayments in
general business taxes were much higher
in those years as well
and so the overpayments is naturally
going to progress with that level of
activity but this would um this would
just be reported these overpayments
would be net of our out of our
unrestricted revenue numbers so you
wouldn't necessarily see it as an
expense
um but we do provide a table in the
focus of cash uh refunds for taxes so it
would be tracked and visible there
thank you
you're welcome
um
representative
followed by representative ames and
spillsberry
and
i
do apologize
am i the only person that doesn't
understand these ranges
on
why it is
that thank you why it is that that
somebody that has to take back three
quarters of what is in their
their uh
credit carry forward
from
year one or year two or whatever
on
doesn't have to take it back right away
on are they allowed to to set up a
schedule whereby they're going to do
on
lower
estimate payments and lower payments for
three four years is that what we're
looking at
i represent this is carolyn lear
um
so i
i understand your confusion i think
what is difficult about trying to
predict how this will show up in
revenues
is that we actually just don't know
how taxpayers will respond we wouldn't
quote unquote let them set up a schedule
but certainly if a taxpayer knew that
this change was coming
we would expect some of them to choose
to reduce their estimate payments
um to avoid a situation where they were
needlessly making estimate payments that
were going to get refunded to them
and that's why
our analysis shows a impact in earlier
years assuming that taxpayers would in
fact start reducing their estimates
certainly some taxpayers won't
change their behavior at all
and those taxpayers
wouldn't receive any of this money back
until they ultimately filed their return
and received a refund
and that's why you also see the fiscal
impact spread into later years
um
and so i think that's
sort of why it's difficult
to um
really pinpoint the year of impact for
this particular change
[Music]
yes i still
don't understand if we were using the
first on the original
charge
for instance wouldn't um
they
aren't they told in 2022
that they have to take that money back
by the language or
so the the language is applicable to
taxes ending on or after december 31st
so this is a 23 tax year um and so
taxpayers might decide to modify
their first quarterly estimate payments
which would fall into fiscal year 2022
but the remaining two estimate payments
as well as their return payment would
fall into 2023 and 2024.
okay thank you so 2024 is when they
would actually have to their tax year
23 which is our fiscal year 24 is when
they would have to act
and but they could start acting this
year
that's correct representative
representative
ames
good thank you uh
yeah mike my question goes back uh a
step here
um
we're talking
right now about uh
sort of options for
reducing the
amount that's booked as uh a credit
carryover um
balance and uh
i'd like to
i'd like to be better informed on why we
need to do this at all
um
you know for years we've seen this
credit carry over
build up and
to the credit if i may use that term of
uh the chair uh he has
expressed concern about that over the
years
um
so much so that i haven't forgotten that
and
uh and now here we are with a provision
in the budget
that
uh
would mandate a
[Music]
reduction
of that
that balance and we're now discussing
well maybe we don't have to
go quite so far maybe we can have have a
lesser cost that we'll have to
take account of in the budget
um
but uh are we sure that if we take that
lesser route then we'll be okay so what
i'm asking what i what i'd like to see
is the
um
whatever information is available
on this subject the
comptroller said that
the auditors have
quote passed
unquote on this
in uh
in previous rounds of discussion around
the cafe but i've expressed concerns
to the fiscal committee
i haven't seen that
discussion
maybe i haven't been listening
but i haven't seen it i don't know
whether it's in writing but i'd like to
see whatever there is and she also
referred to
an entire analysis that gets done each
year
again i haven't seen that
i'd really like to better understand
this and get the best information that's
available
even if we reduce this
as is suggested to the lowest level
the impact as i understand it on the
budget would be
let's say 20 million dollars 25 million
dollars at the lowest
level um for the next uh for the two
years of the next
next budget
um well 25 million dollars if i've got
that right
is
a lot of money i'm hearing from i
imagine all of us are hearing from
members of the finance committee
about their struggle to
deal with
the limitations of the
revenues that they have to meet
pressing needs
so
if we're going to put if we're going to
concur that something needs to be done
and then try to figure out
how much that is i think we need to be
on
on footing that we understand and
in truth i don't
really understand right now the
limitations and what the hazards are
of uh
of taking a different path if this is
something that needs to be addressed
like i think it is something that needs
to be addressed i'll say that
from what i know
but my question then is what's available
can we get better information on this
and i'd also like to know related to
that what other states are doing
uh on this on this uh
you know this
phenomenon i'll call it a phenomenon
that occurs in the context of a very
complex
tax collection and payment system
where
sort of uh it's it's a it's a moving
target you've got estimates coming in
and there are estimates
and then you've got a truing up process
that occurs as new estimates are made
and are flowing in
and so
so this cache that builds up one way or
another is it building up in the way it
has been in new hampshire in other
states
um
so two
to
two questions that are fairly
lengthy i'm sorry about that
uh thank you
i think representative
makes a good point
we need further clarification on why the
audit is passed
and then the
what is the analysis each year
you should be able to understand that
better
and the results of those analysis so
maybe if the comptroller could respond
to that
yes um gladly thank you for the question
again that i think
uh representative ames just explained um
exactly what the struggle has been um it
is a very complicated situation
what we a couple of things we do have
documentation i can certainly provide to
the committee
we have a
finding
that came with the kafir presentation
which was
once we
issued the fy20 kaffir they present that
document to the fiscal committee and
with that
goes along any findings that are of a
significant magnitude and this is one of
them
so for the last two years it has been
discussed
i think what
in terms of why they passed on it is
because with the analysis we've done
which we can certainly provide copies of
to the committee
it came down to a figure that was not
considered material to the state's
financial
statements as a whole
so again it's it's not that it's not a
big number and that is why the auditors
are concerned but from a a high-level
state's financial position as a whole
booking or not booking this liability in
the general fund would not sway
the state's financial position as a
whole so that is why they allowed us to
continue with our current accounting
practice and did not
essentially
modify their opinion if they if they
felt that this was unreasonable the
auditors would modify their opinion
and that would not be a good situation
so
we have been working with them on this
providing as much documentation as we
can but again it is it is an estimate
it's a moving target it's difficult to
nail down exactly what the impact would
be
for all the reasons that have been
previously discussed
so i think they
they do believe strongly that the state
needs to do something
i just want to clarify the the
item the the credit carry over the gross
credit carryover is reported in an
annual report uh by the department of
revenue but we haven't actually booked
that liability in the kafir financial
statements in the audited financial
statements so that's that's the
distinction it is it is a a known
liability but technically unrecorded on
our books so that's problematic
not completely unusual i mean there are
instances when the state incurs
liabilities that are unknown
uh or just not material but
this is this is kind of a big one so
um when you talk about
credit carry over
more than a quarter of a billion dollars
and the auditors
think that that's not
that meaningful
no it's it's that um that refers to the
gross uh
just point in time so
if you know the state were to shut down
today that would be everything we would
owe to taxpayers obviously that's an
unlikely scenario so what we what we
analyze is how much of that gross
liability is expected to get used in the
short term as as as carolyn mentioned
it's it's an in and out type of building
liability and so we use up the oldest
and a new one gets created and when i
say we i mean the taxpayer when they
elect to utilize that
uh liability so the auditors have um
approved of our process in terms of
analyzing that large number and coming
up with a reasonable estimate of at june
30 2020 what our true
liability would be and that was in the
range of 60 million dollars so the 60
million dollar number is what they
passed on and that's been the case the
last two fiscal years
up to up to 200
2017.
it was
170 million dollars or less
and now we're talking 270 million
dollars
which is just a three-year period that's
over a hundred million dollar
it's not a 60 million dollar issue
agreed
again what what the
gross liability has grown with the
tax base so our taxes that we've
collected over the last three years if
you compare fy 17 to 20 have also grown
exponentially so
that
gross carryover number has grown
and they are concerned
but they understood our analysis
which was
attributable to just fiscal 20 so when
they look at a liability they look at
what would we have to pay out
in the short term and that was the 60
million number so the larger number is
more of a long-term
view
isn't that helpful
yes we can provide that information
um
representative
ah thank you mr chair i had a couple of
questions
um
previously it was stated that no other
state has
a cap as this budget suggests
what language is available from other
states is one thing i'd like to know
and
following up on that is it appears to me
that companies would put money or would
pay money on an estimated tax
in a good year in order to have money
there
in a bad year
so wouldn't this
budget process
be very very delatorious to business
operations it seems to me would be
hitting them with uh
both they would money being paid back to
them which they'd have to pay for
and then they wouldn't have money hidden
away to pay for a bad year
am i am i missing something there
representative early i can i can take
that or at least parts of it
um
and i guess just to take this all a step
back
there are two
different ways that we could address a
problem like this
in one sense we could change our
accounting process right to book this
liability
that would satisfy some of the concerns
have been raised by the auditors
the alternative and what
hb2 proposes to do
is to reduce that liability
so that it is less of an issue under our
current accounting procedure so those
are the two different options you could
do one or the other
or in theory you could do them in
concert
but there are two ways to to look at
this
uh representative really to your
question
yes a business can put away more money
in a good year but the other side of
that in a bad year they have less of a
tax liability because they had a bad
year so it
it does kind of go in both directions
there right you don't necessarily need
to put money
or overpay the state for those economic
downturns because your your liability is
would fluctuate as well
not quite sure that's accurate thank you
for your information like the background
by the way
cameron
major i had a follow-up on my earlier
question
and i somehow became muted and
so if i could
go ahead
and then
it's really it's a it's a
it i had a second question
representative uhler actually flagged it
also is
other states and what's happening in
other states
in terms of credit carry over build up
or not
and uh representative uhlery
appropriately sort of expanded that
question to other states uh
legal response to
the
potential of such a such a buildup how
are they handling it
hi representative this is carolyn from
the dra if i might um i think what you
heard from dana is a discussion
a bit ago about whether or not
the amount that we calculate to be the
cco liability is material as it relates
to the
state's overall revenue and i think why
this isn't so much of an issue in other
states is because
one their business tax um
business taxes make up much smaller
profit of their overall tax base
and they have many more
tax-based revenue streams
and so although this situation occurs in
other states
because business taxes are much less
important to them
the cco issue simply isn't material to
their overall
financial position
um
which is why we have been unable i
suggest um
much from other states on this issue
it's sort of unique to us
you've asked but you've not been able to
get anything
that's accurate
we we participate in a number of various
um tax administration consortiums and
groups and we've sent out this question
to list serves and haven't got much
helpful in return good that's what i
needed to know thank you all set up
yes
thank you mr chairman
um at the point i put my hand up we
hadn't really shifted away from the
liquidity questions to the accounting
questions
but i think we need to have both of them
in the balance here
and and anything you do may
tend to affect
liquidity more favorably accounting less
favorably and vice versa
so it seems to me it's very conventional
in taxation to have estimates which are
just guesses
and uh to then have an excess and
to leave it on account instead if to ask
for a refund
what seems to me here to be
unconventional
is the magnitude of it as matthew
indicated there are examples
where business taxpayers have 200 to 300
percent
of their expected next year liability on
account
and we've certainly seen a lot of growth
in the last four years so
to state the obvious
it's not just a question of a hit on
revenue in the next several years but
clearly we've been booking inflated
revenue
for at least the last four years
every time this escalates
we're essentially claiming more revenue
than
we believe and that deceives us
in terms of uh you know what assumptions
we make in the finance committee for
spending
so i guess my question while we're
trying to solve this overhang
is what are we going to do to solve or
or
change our practices
uh incrementally
uh it's one thing to say that there's a
an estimate process and a surplus
or a carry forward
but it's an entirely different thing to
say we don't book it
so why don't we have an annual
reconciliation the estimates come in in
quarters and at the end of the year
a calculation is done and at least on
that incremental basis for the year that
we're talking about
why don't we book the liability
so i think coupled with this question of
how to work off the overhang
we need to change our practice
and i can respond to that if you'd like
um it's a great a great synopsis and it
has that has been the the struggle
um
we could book the entry
and it would it would affect our surplus
that we report in our audited financial
statements
what what path comptrollers have tried
to avoid is sort of
a concept of two sets of books so
you make
decisions budgetarily based on certain
revenue estimates and we track how we do
with that if you have a large
end-of-year liability that sort of
throws all of that out and then reduces
your surplus significantly there is a
thought process that over time
budget writers will will sort of um
discount that
and add that back in
in their minds so what we've tried to
avoid is having an
audited gap-based financial statement
surplus number and a separate budgetary
base or plus number we we've always
wanted them to be consistent
so
there has not been a push to make this
large end of year
as you say reconciliation type entry
just to avoid that thought over the over
time becoming two different sets of
numbers
if that helps
i i guess i understand the thought
process but it's sort of like we don't
want to make the number
explicit and vivid because they might
discount it versus let's hide it and be
oblivious to it
right i mean i think from an accountant
purely accountant standpoint uh booking
the liability is the right thing to do
purely from the accounting standards but
again then then you turn to the
materiality discussion and with any type
of entry like this there's a
determination by management and the
auditors if it would materially change
people's views of the financial
statements again like you said we've
potentially over collected so we've
reporting somewhat inflated revenue
numbers and
if we were to change that or would we
would we materially change
the user's view of our audit single
statements and again with the number
that we're talking
um from uh
after we analyze the true liability um
it has not been
our view that it would materially change
a reader's view of the state's position
so danger if i understand that
if you book it that's the correct thing
to do if you don't book it and you keep
the process the way it is it's more of a
political
action that we take
right i don't want to use the term
correct or not correct because in all
ways we
we strive to follow
gap accounting standards and we have an
audited opinion that says in all
material respects we do
so it is a political discussion
in the sense that
again there are certain
view the surplus statement which is not
an audited financial statement but it's
a highly used surplus statement
in our financial statements
the reality of that is that is the
document that budget writers rely on
so there has always been a political
side to this discussion
okay um any further questions on
on this part if not i'm going to go to
represent
bernstein and then followed by
representative elliot and and romney and
albany
representative bernstein thank you mr
chair
my question is from matthew twice during
your opening remarks
you said uh for one reason or another
companies
have uh
remitted maybe two or they haven't
carried forward account 200 maybe 300
percent of the tax liability
one reason would be to minimize the
federal tax liability are there other
reasons why companies do this it just
seems
unconscionable to have a whole pile of
cash sitting in concord
when it could be in your own corporate
treasury
and i would also invite dra to respond
but i think certainly you know if you
want to mute your federal tax liability
this is one way to do it the other thing
to think about with large multinational
companies that file taxes in
you know 50 different countries in 50
different states new hampshire is just
such a small piece of their
overall tax
that it becomes a rounding error in some
instances
so it's one of those things that it's
easy to look at new hampshire you know
as the the state officials that that you
all are and you think we're the most
important thing but for a fortune 500
it might be a fraction of one percent of
what they pay in tax
um and it might just not have that same
weight but carolyn if you have other
thoughts on scenarios
i think you have it exactly right matt
it's i if you look at the demographic of
taxpayer who has the most egregiously
large
cco on account at the taxpayer that new
hampshire's impact on their overall tax
picture is very very small
thank you
hey and carolyn
how
high
does the older payment go
percentage wise
melissa i don't know if you have the
highest
available to you right now to answer
that question
i don't have it in front of me at the
moment but i can say there were um there
were ones that were in the thousand to
two thousand percent
uh over the tax liability
so it's all over the place
it really is
i think with the 102 or 200 you're
capturing the bulk of them the rest are
probably outliers but they are they are
there are some rather high ones out
there
thank you
all right uh
i'm going to go to
another one that hasn't asked a question
yet represented elliott
representative elliott you're muted
thank you mr chairman uh it's in regard
to what
representative ames said a few minutes
ago
about why are we dealing with this at
all
so my question to you mr chairman is
what exactly is our responsibility as
the ways and means committee to do about
this situation are we going to have a
motion on the floor whether we're going
to go this way or that way or
are we just going to
drop the whole issue all together
as i started this discussion this
morning
we
called our comptroller treasurer and the
dra together
so we can better understand
the legality of what's going on
and is it a good
practice
in our other states
practicing it the same way we are
and uh
also is there another if we continue
with this
is there another way that we can do this
which
doesn't make such an impact on our
revenue
and that was a discussion so we could go
through and then make a decision
what we need to do because we are
the committee that's responsible for
coming up with the estimates of what any
legislative changes proposed in house
bill 2 will have on our revenues and
that's why we're here okay i get it
thank you very much mr chairman
okay uh representative romney
i'm gonna uh
again practical uh comment here
obviously house ways and means
estimates
how much money that finance can budget
to spend 22 and 23.
and uh we've done our first pass at
estimates we're going to be working on
our second pass today and tomorrow
but we also have gone through a house
bill 2
and have estimated the impact
with the help of dra
on revenues
that are
come out to be negative uh in terms of
some of the tax reductions
so
we we broke that news to to
to finance
the question is
i want to make sure
that
this issue is the same
and that we it looks like no matter what
option we choose if we decide to move
forward with this
that there is going to be a reduction in
what i call revenue and you guys have
got to correct me now
for finance to be able to spend
so
you are
is it appropriate for us to put in our
list for finance
an additional reduction depending on
what we decide on
to to say you have less money to spend i
i want to understand this
i'm still struggling between the cash
issue
and the revenue issue
uh maybe maybe dra can start with that
and perhaps the the controller
i want to make sure
that when we update our report for
finance
that
we and
whatever option we pick here
that it is indeed a reduction in revenue
or money that that can be spent in in
22 and 23.
yes this is dana call i would agree it
does need to be reflected because it
would be a reduction of unrestricted
revenue
and it depends which option you choose
as to how large it is in the 2223 period
i think that that was the presentation
that melissa gave right i mean it sounds
like a different question but
mr chair but i want i think it was
important to ask that
and i have a second question
for matt
matt
would
what if we decided to wait a year and
create a bill around this
and
maybe even form a study within ways and
means
to
study this more
it doesn't look like it's the end of the
world here it's an issue that we've been
living with for a long time
uh
it's
this this hb2
uh
section
has brought to light that that maybe we
should be acting on this uh
what would the governor's reaction be if
we
delayed this a year
uh to allow us to work on this
even more
i would want to bring that back to the
governor specifically but what i would
say is our intent is to find a way to
address this issue that
because again this is a one-time impact
right once we've corrected if you will
you know there's not an ongoing
uh year-to-year impact beyond just how
it is
dispersed between that initial phase-in
um so if it's a matter of pushing this
out to taxable periods starting
in or ending in 2023 or 2024 that could
be one way
but i believe it'd be difficult to do
this outside of the budget process
because this is a a sizable one-time
fiscal impact
but let me report back and i'm happy to
circle up
let me ask you follow up on then uh matt
uh
in your in your revenue estimates did
you did you
include the impact of this
so thank you for the question
representative abrami when we
first approached this issue i think our
position was the same as some of those
members of the committee that understood
this to be strictly a cash impact
it's become apparent in subsequent
conversations with dra that
there is a one-time fiscal impact
because of how the state has been
booking this revenue
so i can't point to a specific line in
our revenue estimates
that directly deal with this basin
especially given the uncertainty
over how this impact
cascades across fiscal years
but we do understand now that there is a
fiscal impact associated
with these sections okay well thank you
i just want to remind the committee
that you're all given a spreadsheet
called changes in revenue due to
legislative changes
and the
in there it shows the
impact for
house bill 2 has written
what it would be if we use the mid-range
of those four years
and on the
credit carry forward
that it would impact the taxes
negatively in 22 by 15 men
and 23 by 39.8 million
but as we heard from
melissa a little while ago
she said that practically
rather it wouldn't be the mid-range it
would be towards the higher end the
range if that was the case
then
it would be
and we're here today to understand
what's going on here
and is it we go and do we want to
continue it and that's why we have to
control and the treasurer and the dra
all right and there's been some good
questions
the next question is representative
elementary
followed by representative easy and
represented
thank you mr chairman
on
the the only place that this can should
go would be uh on a reduction of the
revenues from the business
taxes and
i've been on and
i've been trying to think is there a way
that we could set this up so that we
would be using
the
on
the ending up with the hundred percent
given the fact that the dra is saying
that
it's mostly smaller businesses that are
only paying a couple of
quarters in advance
that consist of the ones under that and
that the problem is the ones that are
keeping a hundred percent or more in
there
but also spread it out
over more years would that make these
ranges smaller so that we had some
ability to forecast how much
was going to have to be taken off the
business taxes each year as well as
spread it out over more years so that it
would not be as painful to the budgets
because i can i can see
the finance committee ours and the
sentence
on just removing
this thing because they don't want to
deal with it as the fiscal committees
have not wanted to deal with it
but on this is a problem
does not date back just five years or
ten years on
represent the our chairman has been
talking about this and i was talking
about it at the beginning and then kind
of gave up
about this since practically for maybe
20 years
and and it has been growing a lot during
that time i think it must have taken a
serious dip that we did not realize did
not get told about during the great
recession
because it was up there before that
and came down at some point and went
back up but it goes
it dips at our times of worst pain when
the recession
the recession is involved and the state
cannot afford but must pay back the
refunds
so
i think that we do we do need to deal
with it but if we could if there is a
way to write this to
to spread out the pain
more evenly and longer
uh that would be good
thank you caroline and melissa can you
respond to that
about spreading it out
my representative this is carolyn
um
we you saw our draft options we are
happy
to draft up some more options if that
would be helpful to the committee
um two ideas that come to mind to me
would be for us to show you what it
would look like if you capped ccos at
and stopped there or if you capped them
at 200 percent but then waited
um more waited a couple tax years before
implementing the second
um
second reduction to 100 i think both of
those options
would be ways to um
to
spread out and minimize the fiscal
impact
do you have a
spreadsheet showing that
okay it's not correct now
but i just have a follow-up i think one
of our problems is that this is just
showing up in the budget now
to be done now and there hasn't been
time to think it out a lot but if we
leave it any longer
on
people may never do it again
and it is really bad in recessions i
think
but this is something you could do
quickly
carolyn
yes i think we could turn that around
pretty quickly
okay
are you all set for
representatives
yes thank you uh
thank you mr chairman um i have a
comment and then a question for dra
first the comment
is um basically that um
it seems like we may have to do some
sort of phased approach because if we do
the quick cut at 50 percent
over time we need to understand why this
is going up because now it's 50 the
increase will be smaller but if we're in
this direction where this is continuing
to increase
even if you're sending 50 back but the
total increase keeps increasing
you're still gonna at some point say
okay now even though we're only allowing
50 percent
the number is huge again and we have to
do another cut so we may have to look at
some sort of uh phased approach
um and then something that takes into
account that it's continuing to increase
or at least understand why it's
continuing to increase to address that
problem
that's my comment the question for dra
is
one of the things that that i had asked
in a previous meeting was
um
the idea is that companies are trying to
avoid federal tax and that's why they're
letting this number get so big but my
question is
is that really true because i know that
i mean i have an llc and if i've
overpaid
then i get a 1099 g
and that that money then has to be
applied uh as income so i'm not sure how
companies are avoiding federal tax by
letting this number build up so i would
ask dra that that question
thank you for the question
representative i understand that the
state only issues 1099 g's when we pay a
refund
um we don't issue a 109g
for a taxpayer having a cco on their
account
and i believe the logic behind that is
that we don't know whether the cco on
their account is um actually intended to
be a payment of their upcoming estimate
liability versus
extra money that they're just parking
there
uh follow-up
in my case i don't ask for a refund i
leave the money there
and
so it can pay for
um future tax liability
so i am still getting a 1099 g even
though i'm not asking for a refund
or if you
to send me that information offline i
can certainly look into that and
understand why that
is happening
it's it's also happening on my personal
tax where my wife and i are proprietors
and some rental property and when we've
overpaid
the next you know next uh tax cycle we
get a 1099 g
even though i never again even there i
don't ask for a refund
so i it seems like it's a general policy
but yeah i can
talk to you offline
representatives
thank you um
i just want to be sure that we get the
written analysis there's a question to
the chair to make sure we get
the
background information that we talked
about earlier with the controller
and also the
uh analyses that have been done of
different options by dra so far that was
shown by melissa on
the screen
and then i
it's really a comment i guess uh it was
said that this is
a one-time problem a correction would be
a one-time thing
i i don't think so i think that it
relates to how we estimate revenues
and uh i believe this statement is true
that in effect we've been over
estimating revenues for the business tax
in at least the recent years
because they have included
or they've failed to include refunds
that the businesses are entitled to but
don't ask for
it's that overhang that uh
representative um
spillsbury uh spoke to
uh so that's a comment but i'd like to
get that information
right
so the action items with the controller
is to get
the analysis each year
and then also why
the audit is passed
pass on this issue from booking
and non-booking
and from the dra to look at
different analysis
uh
say a 100 trigger versus a two hundred
dollar or even larger trigger
and
that's what i have for the reaction
and my
just a comment uh mr chair uh finances
is going to be looking for us to do the
updated revenues
and give the updated revenues on friday
and they've been really pushing for that
and
it doesn't sound like
we're going to have a conclusion on this
piece uh by then
unless we strive hard to come up with a
a compromise
so we're going to have to go in with our
best guess on this
uh for them because they want to have
their their uh budget done by sometime
next week i guess
uh and that's why they've been pushing
us
so
uh i i don't know i i'm not quite sure
what we're gonna tell finance on friday
when it comes to this particular item
other than give them a range i guess
and uh
but that's just a comment or i don't
know if you want to react to that but
yes we will have to have revenues
finished tomorrow so we can give the
finance on
friday and what i'm hoping is the ra can
give us their spreadsheet
looking at it
of the 100
million and 100
so
we have more so we can make an
investment
from what the uh
falls legislation looks like right now
so we'd make an amendment
to incorporate that if we don't make an
amendment to incorporate that
then we have to use
the limit
that uh we'll have to use what's in
hb2 now
a 50
trigger point
and then we have from the dra with the
ranges
and what we'll need for the r8
is
do we pick
towards the top of the range
or can we do the middle of the range for
those two years
so so the plan is to have that done by
tomorrow then yes okay that's what i
just wanted we have a lot of work to do
between now and tomorrow right now
we're concentrating on the
on the legislation in the house bill 2
that
only affects this credit move forward
when we get through with this discussion
we will go through and review the rest
of them
and they're in hospital too but i think
they're pretty well set
and mr chair
i i hope that we can get the
comptroller's uh background information
as well
on the same timetable
and contol
provide us that information
i can
i can send that out just after this
meeting
excellent thank you so
much and what do we need on this issue
mr chairman
representative
we are
keeping on
melissa
and carolyn here all day i think when
are they going to be able to do these
other things
i'm sure they'll
figure that out
anything else on this issue
relative to the cco
okay i don't i see no hands and thank
the controller and the
treasurer
and the budget director
and so what i'd like to do is go to the
other issues
the other items
there are legislative changes
proposed in house bill 2
that'll affect our revenues
and just
just to review them
you each have the
worksheet that was sent out
dated 316 which was yesterday
and i'd like
to work on that
and most of these uh
we need affirmation from the dra
the first item is the additional dra
auditors
that's actually in house bill 1
and
that would produce
positive revenue of 700 000 thousand fy
22 and 3.2 million fy 23.
those look
mister
chairman which
which word sheet is this it sounds like
i got a very uh
partial on thing from
from you that didn't include the
auditors at all
is that what we were talking about
the one i sent out yesterday does chris
can you bring that up
press shy
do you see it now
okay there is the online toke
this is additional dre auditors
it's actually in house bill 1
and
it would bring in
positive 700 022 and 3.2 million and 23.
and the question to the dra these
good estimates
yes representative those are good
estimates
any questions from the committee
uh norm
brownie
would it be helpful
for finance to in some of these and some
of these we have it going out to 25
and others we don't
um
wouldn't it be helpful to them to see
what what some of this financial impact
going all the way out to 25 would be
the reason you see the 24 25
is
i wanted to see it myself
okay but we need to
give them the impact on 22 and 23.
and i thought by
uh i would imagine that like on the
auditors
it would settle down close to the 3.2 in
the out years i'm not sure
but we didn't ask the dra that
information
all right
okay
and the
meals in room tax decrease from eight
and a half percent from nine percent to
eight and a half percent with decreased
revenue is 11.4 million
and fy 22 because it's implemented uh
in october
and 11 point i'm 19 million fy23 are
those
still good estimates uh carolyn or
melissa
yes those are good
uh representative allenby followed by
representative ames
representative muted
you muted us so
you're still muted
i'm sorry i was trying to read this in
another format so that i could see it
because i do not have a copy of this one
on
but
on i was on trying to check
i think that they based this decrease on
what was earned in
in uh 2018
or
no
no this one was 2020. that's right there
was another one the bet one was 2018.
so the actual
dollar numbers are related to
to the crash we had in 2020 for
meals and rooms and to what we were
getting
in
fy 18 i think it was
for
the bet
and these
reduction revenues the reduction in
revenues from h hr
that we have in hr11
any sort of questions on the meals and
rooms uh yeah i've got a question
yeah
and it really relates to what
representative army was just bringing up
but i think that the um
to the extent to which we make an
adjustment in the meals and rooms
revenues for
21 22 and 23 there's a direct
relationship to
um the money that will
not come in if the rate's reduced
and we should be working off of
those figures rather than
old figures
it's the 8.5 percent that we
levied instead of 9
i got my numbers right
in those years
against the activity the
the amount of uh
of rums and meals that are
sales that are made
and it's not the amount of sales that
were made years ago
so i think that it's not a huge impact
but it's it's a
two or three million four million i
don't know
it needs to be i i believe has to be
addressed
with a correction for the school
building aid and
and i think there was one other thing
there
for the rooms
we were discussing one tax at a time
do you have
any comments
on representative ames analysis there
um this is carolyn representative um
certainly
our our analysis
analyses always
look back to the most recently completed
tax year um we
customarily don't attempt to sort of
predict what revenues are going to be in
future years to calculate
impacts um which is not to say that it
wouldn't it would be inappropriate for
you to do so um but but we instead rely
on the most recently completed um data
that we
have okay
so represent ames on
the uh
11.4 and the 19 million
and 22 and
do you have an estimate
well my calculation
and i believe i just got some scribbling
from late last night to be honest
i think i used the governor's
number
of
363.2 million
you have to look to see if that squares
with things
and then made the calculation and i came
up with 30.2
million
loss
now that could be wrong somebody needs
to correct this i don't know
but you asked so i'm telling
okay we're going to be reviewing
our estimates
right after we do the hb
two items
uh
these
items are what's in hb2
and what the dra
figures they would
either increase or decrease revenues in
these two years would be
and what you're
saying uh to make corrections for the
meals and rooms tax and you use the
governor's
numbers for the meals and rooms tax
i think i did
i think i think what we should use
because we're talking about we
you know our version of this
is we should have our meals on rooms tax
estimates
uh at the current current law rate
going forward
in hand have those numbers in hand
and then the question is okay
if instead of a nine percent rate we
have an eight point five percent rate
how does that play out
how does that affect that
estimate that we've arrived at
using the nine percent rate
and of course we deduct uh the school
building loan and so forth and the
commissions uh figure into this analysis
too by the way
i guess
it plays out a 2.7
allowed 3
commission
anyway the analysis is just a
mathematical analysis uh calculation
once we
go through our regular revenues
i think so
okay
the next item is the bt threshold
increased to 250 000 and the
also the
business independent value increasing
250 000.
the dra estimates there's no
change in fy 22
but about 3.1 million decrease in fy 23.
the
next one is the bet rate decrease
to 0.55 percent from
0.6
in hospital too
and the
change would be
it would affect our revenue
additional negative 4.7 million dollars
and 22.
minus 13.3 million
those are the dra estimates
the next is the offsetting bpt
revenue increase
due to the
decrease in bt rate
so
in fy23
if you use the credit
most of that credit
towards the bpt
then
the
bpt
revenue increase is going to be
2.8 million dollars
and an increase of 8.1 due to the 13.3
million
decrease
being t
because you're using less credit
uh the next the ib ind tax your phase
out
that have no effect on
as the legislation's written no effect
in 22
minus 6.3 million dollars
in 23
and then it would increase
each year after
i'm on this one
am i muted or not i don't know
uh
this is representative ames if i may yes
um
[Music]
i think this is
this too gets affected by adjusted
um
estimates that we make on the
base the 21 fiscal year 21
ind 22 and 23 given the current five
percent rate
um
certainly for the future years
um probably for fy23 the number the fy23
number i believe should be a little bit
higher because our ind
number the current rate is going to be
higher i believe
and in the
years after that
it will be higher
because we're going to have a higher
higher number to start with
so when you are on the
estimates
we'll come back to this
right
the single sales factor delay
would not affect the 22
but an estimate of 20 million dollars
and 23.
historic racing
um
didn't that check doesn't that 12
million dollar change in 22
pack yes it does um i don't have it
right in front of me it should be lower
it'll take time to roll it out if it
passes
okay okay
it is low and we're gonna have to
correct that number i have a comment on
that
yes
um
okay the fiscal analysis of
of that bill
um i forgot the number is 626.
626 yes yeah
i think uh
i have a question about that uh the uh
analysis assumes a 12
takeout or
uh commit uh i call it's called a
commission
the rest stays with the people who are
gambling
and
the twelve percent is the maximum
allowed by the bill
in practice and i believe in the
testimony we've received
the takeout is about eight percent
um not 12 percent
you'll remember
presentations that took that eight
percent and then divided it amongst the
state and the charities and the
operators um
and
so if you work off of an eight percent
you're going to get a smaller number for
the state
takeoff take out i believe eight percent
uh i think the testimony or documents
that we received
uh is consistent with what the
other states that have historic horse
racing gaming
have uh have taken out um and uh that we
should be working off of that lower
number and making the calculation of the
state's
um
prospective revenue from this
norm can i respond
yes
uh again the 12 million uh
comes from lottery
i can check at lunch
uh double check at lunch to see
how they did the math
is that okay
yep
that makes sense and i just make sure
you're asked about the 12 versus the
eight percent of some
assumption whether they use the 12 or
it probably i think they probably use 10
percent
uh
the calculation is clear uh patrick it's
right there on the face of the
thing is twelve percent of the uh
i'm forgetting the uh gambling number
but it's the gross gaming uh gross
amount bet
that the 12 is not a percentage
12 and 12. it's 12 12 is the commission
um that's the maximum commission in the
bill i mean yeah the way that the math
works is
right
yeah we if we use the 12 percent well it
doesn't matter what we have 12 percent
then 25 of the 12 goes to the state and
charities
and of that 25
uh 35 goes to the charities that's the
way that match plays out but i'll double
check i'll double check that i have to
pull it wasn't the physical
right there's a pretty extensive fiscal
note that i have in my folder here and
it did talk about on
using in 80 uh 88 i think it was going
back to the charity
no 88 questions
the players
yeah
okay you're gonna check
okay the um
the next is
we don't have the
clear
clarification
the business profits tax credit carry
forward limited to 50
and what i did here is i used the middle
of shows on
on the first year 0 to 32
and
in the mid range
on the other but according to melissa
it really should be towards the other
end
and
we'll just wait until we hear from
the dra on this before we plug numbers
in there
the next line 11 which is house bill 591
lynn ober wanted me to put this in here
because they're putting house bill 591
liquor license fees
into
the two
and it amounts to 36
000 each year and
just to make it complete so i put it in
there
these cdf numbers that you see below
are the credit carry forward numbers
that i picked up from
the bra for those various years just
give you some idea what the magnitude of
it is
okay
i'm major this is chris um i'm gonna go
back to the liquor license fee for a
second yes
that's actually a plus not a minus i
know it's small dollars but just
it is a plus
so change that
on your sheets people
thank you chris
i guess i'd like to also comment that
that
particularly for the ind
five-year phase out a
more a complete presentation would have
fy 26 and 27
28 i guess
and would show in the end 135 million
dollars or 130 or whatever number we
fix on loss
you'd like to have it shown on this
i really would i think that's uh that's
a part of the picture that's also you
know
you can do that
so can you do that uh add that
chris
yeah i just gotta find the information
and i can add it okay
um got too many files open at the moment
too
now what i would like to do is
go into
regular
revenues
and chris has
sent out the worksheets
and before i do that
let's take a five-minute break
and be right back in five minutes
[Music]
you
hello hey chris
hold on hold on a second
yeah chris
yeah
can you bring up
uh the
spreadsheet that the dre
would put out on the 10th of march
their
newer estimate range
yeah i can do that okay that's what
we're going to do next
all right thank you
[Music]
janine
is going to bring up the spreadsheet
that the dra put out on the 10th of
march
that
everybody should have a copy of but
they'll be able to see it on the
screen
yes
that's good
i let devin
rodrick in just in case he's needed oh
yes good
thank you
yeah
yeah i think mostly everybody should be
back by now
you have one hand raised that's our
guest
excuse me i i don't know if i have this
um it could be that
representative omni sent me quite a few
things but i don't
the only spreadsheet i got was the one
that we were looking at earlier
yeah
i thought i did send it to you but it's
just
it's a single page it isn't really a
spreadsheet okay
i'll look again thank you
and and that's what it's entitled i may
have put dra in the front of it so you'd
know
has the nice colors
it's a lot easier to look at than our
worksheet she did
that green on there is almost the same
color as my living room
all right are we all set
okay uh what i want to do next
since we have the dra
is to go over the dra revenues
associated
with
our total revenues
and they provided us a sheet dated
march 10th
which up
updates their revenue estimates
and the first is the business taxes
and
the committee agreed on fy 21 of 809.8
million dollars
in the business taxes
and eight
26.5 million dollars
on fy 22
and 840 million dollars
on fy 23.
uh you can see as we go out in years we
deviate a lot more so now if the dra
would
explain what they did
for changes
associated with the business taxes
sure thank you representative major for
the record melissa rollins senior
financial analyst at department of
revenue
um so this was just a quick update when
i say quick i just mean we kept all our
assumptions the same that we have
previou previously
uh presented to you all we did in this
scenario is take out february estimates
and reduce them with february actuals
and because business taxes
performed
much higher than we anticipated
for february the number range has
increased what i do want to note that
special about
are different about business taxes for
fiscal year 21
is that in february february we did
receive some anomalous tax notice
payment activity
that we do not anticipate
to continue in 22 and 23. so that being
said it was about 10 million dollars
which should be recognized in fiscal
year 21 and is included in our ranges
however when we did the growth for 22
and 23 or for 22 excuse me we received
removed 10 million from the fiscal year
21 base
and grew
that figure by the 1
in 3
percent i think that's the only
difference that we did on these except
again remove our february estimates for
our low and high and replace them with
uh february actually
and
um
prior to that
your low was 799.8
and your high this is for 21 824.2
and so they went up quite a bit in fy
21.
that's correct
what we did
we chose 809.8
for fy21
uh
and you only did this because of
the february results
you made these changes based on the
february results
that's also correct
and that would affect
22 and 23.
questions from many
reps
susan you muted
um you didn't finish calling me i
thought
um
are we only dealing with 21 right now
because i wanted to question the growth
numbers
with uh melissa
21 right now
um
what you're saying is there's the 8 17
that you have in 21 does not show that
at 10 million dollars
uh no
no the 817 includes the 10 million
so it should be
if you want to compare with our numbers
your
807.0 and we were
809.8 which is
essentially the same
that's for growing
from 21 to 22 however in fiscal year 21
you want to res you want to include that
anomalous receivable
so
you would want to add 10 million into
your estimate
so
if we added 10 million into our
estimates for 21 it would be
819.8
if we didn't change anything
that's correct
go ahead represented on me
thank you i still i i'm particularly
interested in 22 and 23 so i don't want
to talk until then thanks okay well
that's what we're on now as 20 and 22
you you took the 817
and you increased it one and three
percent which gave you the 815
what
no we removed 10 million we moved the 10
million yes to grow the base because we
didn't anticipate that happening again
in 22.
and so you used 07
by 1 to give you 815
and then the three percent gives you
855.9
that's correct
mr chairman if we're on 22-23 can i ask
my question yes
thank you
on
i'm
wondering originally you set growth
rates in 22
uh
22 of uh one to three percent
uh thinking that it would be slow to
take off that was before
on
the recovery package i think in december
but certainly before the american
recovery plan
on that's just been passed and i've been
reading the blasts going out from my
uh regional chamber of commerce the
upper valley business alliance telling
people about all the things they can
apply for and that they have to start
applying immediately
on
and um
i'm wondering
if one if
if the growth path is going to be more
for
and maybe less for 23 than
than what you'd originally been looking
at
sure i think first off i just want to
say that's a great question and a great
point
we have not re-analyzed our numbers
for
[Music]
for fiscal year 22 or fiscal year 23 we
intend to do that um the end of this
month
obviously like you said the stimulus
package came in since we've done to what
the one to three percent range and the
four to six percent revenues have also
come in um a little bit ahead of it so
we're definitely
planning on looking that again looking
at that again to see if the one to three
still makes sense and the four to six
makes sense
so you'll be adjusting
the
end of the month
that yes that's our goal
like to consider adjusting before then
in our estimates thank you
and what would your recommendation be
represented
elmi
represent all me
uh you're muted
my laptop just pulled something up on
top of you i'm sorry uh this would be
totally off the wall but
but
i would
we're talking about
uh fy 22 on this summer through
next summer
and
on
the restaurants in particular and and
lodging are getting quite a boost uh the
tourism markets seem to be
growing
quite a lot right now uh
and
the question is whether there would be
growth in the biggest
companies that are the ones that we are
on getting most of our business taxes
from
and which have been doing very well with
the pandemic
on
so i
i can't wrap my head too much around
this but i would like to
to
maybe conservatively promote that to two
percent to four percent in the first
year and then
maybe four to five percent the year
after
so
so you're recommending two to four
percent for the 22 i mean yeah 22 and
and what for 23.
um
four to five percent
not not quite as much growth because it
would already be occurring
this year and this next year starting
this summer
actually starting in a few
weeks but
all right um
represent ames
thank you um
so first on fiscal year 21
we're now
more than halfway through march
and
so my question
to melissa is
whether and i think we've gotten some
revenue
reports uh for the last couple of days
which for business taxes
are
look pretty good at least what i saw
i haven't seen today's
so
you know this is an unfair question but
uh can can you
are you more optimistic about march
now than the uh number that we have
before us
assumes
i think that's a great a great question
representative ames i was actually
thinking the same thing before coming in
here and seeing um the report today
as you know the revenue flows in now
pretty heavily and we get a good idea
this week of where we're ending in march
and as you stated
including um the revenue we received on
monday um
it's looking it's looking optimistic
it's looking better than i think we had
anticipated uh the the factor that's
holding out a little bit is what we
issue for refunds and how much that
decreases it
uh
however we can get a slight idea of
what's sitting out there
and there isn't anything
major that would push us at this point
past what we looked at last year for
refunds
so i definitely think
obviously again i want to have it one
more thing that april is a big month as
you know um right now we're basically
looking at partnerships for partnership
returns but if we waste based
on the trend that we're seeing so far
i think there's definitely room in
fiscal year 21 to move up your range or
your number for fiscal year 21
um
based on the performance so far for
march
i have a related question that you're
mentioning
what do you call it refunds
um triggers uh i haven't really
understood that
when does dra report out refunds
is is there a delay there while you sort
of gather them together or
do they just get reported out as they
come
sure so we issue refunds every wednesday
they do go through a review process so
some refunds if they
come in and nothing has changed on the
return meaning there's no math errors
that anything changed those refunds get
automatically auto issued is what we
called and they get issued right away
if they have issues where what their
refund is is different than what they
requested then those do get reviewed by
our taxpayer services group or if they
are large dollar numbers they do get
bumped to our audit division
and that
does slow the process down but we try to
avoid at all costs paying interest on
these refunds which is accrued after 60
days and we very rarely hit that so
we're issuing and turning these around
within 60 days of receiving these
refunds as long as we have all the
information needed and i think what you
said is that you don't have a big bunch
of
questionable refunds sitting there that
are under review
yeah so we're always monitoring these on
a regular basis we have a report we have
um we do have refund sitting out i think
last time we looked it was around three
or four million dollars again those get
reviewed first so they're not always
accurate but looking at that number
which was as of a couple of days ago
that would equal if we issued all of
those that would put us at the same spot
as last year but again those are
unreviewed refunds so they understand
that's helpful
um
okay and mr chair if i could uh just
speak to 22 and 23 for a moment
melissa you said that
you
if you hold the refund for over 60 days
you have to pay interest
and that's
only for those that request a refund
right
that's correct but on the credit carry
forward
when you refund that
are there is there any interest paid on
that
i think i again and carolyn can correct
me if i'm wrong i believe those again
it's 60 days so it's not considered a
refund request until it's requested as a
refund it's not um when the money came
in because of that um usage of money so
once they request that refund interest
is paid
if we exceed 60 days from the request of
the refund what about if hospital two
passes
and
and you have to
a particular business
a million dollars over the 50
point
do you have to pay
interest on that
i believe again the ref it would can be
considered a refund request once they
file their 2023 return and that 50 is
calculated we would then have 60 days to
pay
that and if we hit it within the 60 days
we wouldn't be paying interest
okay even though it comes from the
credit card
forward
yes okay thank you go ahead
representative
sorry
oh no that's good um
so turning to 22 and 23
i just wanted to pick up on what
representative volney
had uh suggested i think
certainly i and probably all of us are
feeling more
optimistic uh than we were and i it's
probably true of dra
because of
the changes that have occurred both
with the with the vaccine and the kohit
19 and
with the enactment of the
federal uh stimulus bill
america restores act or something like
that
and
[Music]
and also
just the
the pent-up
demand that's out there we all know
about that and people are feeling um
increasingly able to do what they've
been wanting to do
so i think this all adds up to
a lot of economic activity
i'm not
i think this is really going to happen
across the nation but uh
also in new hampshire
and
that leads me to be optimistic and i i
wouldn't embrace i don't
this isn't hard science obviously but
the two two
to four percent range um but i would in
this in the following year because i've
seen a number of forecasts that do this
i would have at the high end of the
range the six percent that dra is
showing here
the professional forecasters are all
upping their forecasts
um
and they're clearly feeling as as
liberated and optimistic as
as the rest of us um so that's my
comment on that you would say four to
seven percent
six
six to seven
four two six
[Music]
thank you i want to go back to 2021 and
sorry if i missed something but if i
look at the dra
high and low it would seem like 828
million would be fy 21. you could walk
the 10 million out and then use
818 million for the base for 22.23
and then i'd also go along with the
other representatives that we could now
boost up the percents after 2021.
you use the base of how much on 21
for 21 first based on theirs it would be
828 million
but then you take out the 10 million
and then for 22 and 23 you use 818
million if i'm doing that right melissa
yes
that's correct
okay
and would you repeat again for the 22
what i'd do for 22 and 23 i would just
support what the other people have said
that i think we should increase the
percents
the total four and the uh four to six
correct okay
representative yearly
i'm sorry you've already answered my
question
representative abram
you're muted that
thank you mr chair um
can you give us a sense of what we're
going to do tomorrow when we come up
with final numbers
how we're going to approach this i know
individuals are now giving their
thoughts about where they think this
should wind up
which is great
but what's the process tomorrow are we
going to each provide enough numbers
to the the revenues they think that we
should change
and take an average uh how how are we
going to proceed tomorrow so we we have
a better sense
that's what i figured today today we
would go through all the dra webinars
and then
tomorrow morning
we would go through the
non-dra revenues and then proceed to
committee as a whole
doing
all the revenues
and what i would suggest is that this
afternoon when we're through
with the dra
is that the
democrats caucus
and we'll caucus the republicans
and then
we'll get together tomorrow
we'll recaucus
today we'll be caucusing on the
era revenues and that's the bulk of the
revenues and also
focusing on what we heard
relative to the
credit carryover tomorrow we should have
the information from
the comptroller and the dra
so to help us make that decision
on the credit carryover effect
so what we would be doing tomorrow is
like we did last time that we would be
working off of a uh
one republican number and one democrat
number and then trying to compromise um
make it a lot easier yes yes
and the only other i have
mr chair is that
when we think about the business taxes
again when it comes to 23
having to do a single sales factor
um
i i think we we assumed that single
sales factor is going to go into effect
and coming up with the numbers and then
that
for 23 and business taxes that and on
the other sheet
we indicate that there's still a 20
million dollar
difference that if if indeed it winds up
that and by the way just fyi for
everybody
i'll be testifying on monday and senate
uh ways and means
on our bill
uh that uh
will delay the single sales factor
that that's coming up on monday and i
did talk to the chair
of senate finance
uh he called me about it and i explained
our position
and he even suggested well what if we
only hold off a year instead of three
years four years
and i said well
let's talk i know to the whole committee
you know so anyway but
so i i i just want to put that out there
but
right now
law is single sas factor goes into place
in 23
for uh and that we should think that way
and that
you know unless we change our mind
that
and on the sheet that we give to finance
we're going to reduce
if they decide to put
into house bill 2
the impact is 20 million dollars
back into the business taxes so when
you're thinking about the number
think of it that way in two pieces we do
the revenues tomorrow
we're going to do two things
one
is the revenues
using current law
as if we're generating a new hr11
we're also going to do
hb2
which b2 will have the single sales
factor in there and that's where we'll
put the effect on
single sales factor into the hb2 numbers
but the
house resolution numbers has to be
current law
right
i'm agreeing
okay thank you
oh
anything else representative romney nope
that's it
all right
um
so
what we're discussing now will help
in both of our caucuses
as we try to come up with what we
estimate these revenues
should be going to based upon
change in the economy the
vaccinations and
the stimulus payments obviously
we don't have the
analysis in this payment i've asked for
it
nobody has it at this point in time but
just as soon as we get
this is available we'll be meeting we'll
go over that
and then that'll show up in our april
estimates
all right anything else
mr chair yes um i think uh maybe
yesterday you uh
mentioned the ppp
issue
yes
um
what's how are we going to deal with
that
um
what
that should be coming over as senate
bill 40 i believe
and
if
it doesn't come over
if they treat that the same as they did
the uh
split
the meals and room taxes they passed it
unanimously
and then tabled it so they can use it
in the uh in their budget
the ppp
that came out of their committee
i guess unanimous
then it will be going to the full
senate uh
we're going to spend time on that
i don't agree with that and there's a
lot of other factors that we need to
take into consideration
and we'll do that
once we get the budget numbers squared
away
i have a uh
additional wrinkle that
came to my attention
i guess when was it this morning
early this morning um
from tax notes
and um
the it relates to the ppp and the
taxability of it so our situation is uh
our tax supplies and the question the
proposal is to
retroactively remove them
the
new stimulus bill
has a provision in it
that prohibits
states from reducing
from using stimulus money
to
reduce taxes
and
the
the tax note related to california where
they've got a
different situation but they've been
advised
they've they pulled back on a proposal
that would
relate to the taxation of
ppp
because of
concerns they had
that it might
their proposed action might not comply
with that tax that new restriction
that's in
the new stimulus bill
so i wonder if dra could take a look at
that and
advise on it
carolyn and melissa did you get that
my representative i'm very aware of um
what that what you're speaking of we've
been monitoring it as have other states
and we've heard some noise
um across various list serves i would
suggest um to the committee
that that issue is probable probably
exceeds
our capacity to advise you
um relative to potential tax cuts and i
think
probably is more appropriately addressed
to the department of justice i'm happy
to facilitate the transfer of that issue
to them um but that's that's a big issue
for sure
thank you
i agree it's a big issue and that's a
good suggestion
mr chair on
i've done a certain amount of of trying
to understand this with the uh staff of
the delegation in d.c
and the answers that i'm getting are
essentially that this is all been booted
to the u.s treasurer
on and that that person is supposed to
clarify
clarify things
and that on
on
we will have some um
pushing from the the uh senators from
new hampshire
to try to get
get on results that are advantageous to
new hampshire
but
that's about all i could collect
i i think once you see the analysis i've
been working on
on the ppp
i hope you get the same
reaction that i have
number one
we are
different from every other state
our
corporate business tax
represents a huge amount of our total
taxes
and the corporate business tax in all
the other states represents a very small
amount of their total taxes some it's
zero but the vast majority
represents about zero to six percent of
their total taxes
so
they can do what they want with the pp
and it doesn't make much of an effect
but it sure makes a whale of an effect
in new hampshire
if if we
don't tax
if if we remove that from the taxes
coming in
because it already is removed
if they use the money the way they're
supposed to
is that
that's money coming in
then you which is
six at least sixty percent
towards wages
then you get the federal deduction
but then
you also get to do the deduction
because it's an expense
you also get the deduction
and that
if you
spend it
on things such as
rents and all the other things that's a
deduction so if you use it for what's
intended you don't take taxes on it and
if you and then if you take
and
and get another deduction you get a
double deduction
massachusetts doesn't tax it
but they tax it
as personal
income
for the corporation at five percent
and then they also tax
the wages
as the income tax
they also tax
anything that's
that these people they got the wages
buying certain goods and
services and so
they get more back they don't pay taxes
on it plus they're also generating taxes
from personal income tax in the total
amounts
and the taxes from their income tax on
the wages and taxes from
the
sale of goods and services and
and i've compared it to other states too
so
i didn't
let's go on to this pack we need to get
these revenues out first
okay
sorry you asked about the ppp but
um
the next
anything else on the business taxes
what time is it going to be
we go to meals and rental tax
and using the dra
sheet that they came up with on
march 10
melissa or caroline you want to
tell us what you what you did on this
so again for meals and rentals
we removed our february estimate and
replaced it with february actuals which
as you can see it is bigger than our
original estimate because february
performed better than what we
expected for m r
and then again we haven't made any
modifications on any of the taxes growth
rates for 22 and 23 so we still have the
8 to 11 percent for 22
and the 4 to 6 percent for 23.
and how that compares with our estimates
is that
the low is you know 2.7
for 21
and
compared to
the estimated 301
and their high is 320 so we're on the
lower side of that part
and then
as far as
we estimate 328
and we're on the low side of their
estimate
and 29 we estimate 349 and we're also on
the low side so
comments
we know that
the restaurants are starting to pick up
people are getting inoculated
the economy is picking up
it's going to have an effect on
on these things it's up to us to
determine what that's going to be
represented southwest
uh yes this is
really the one that's always concerned
me the most i think it'll be
really impactful what happens with
tourism
and especially the venues that are near
theaters and
all those kinds of things that may be
slow to open
but i don't really know the breakdown of
um
meals and rentals as far as how many are
just the mcdonald's places you know so
on but i think it is going to be uneven
um depending on where those businesses
are located and what activities are
around them
okay uh
chris
who is it tomorrow we're going to have
coming in
to talk to us about
the businesses
and tourism
so you have um commissioner caswell will
be in tomorrow with director arnos
harnos i believe it um from travel and
tourism you'd have to have them come in
and just talk to you about
basically what does their
marketing fund generate
in revenue to the state and just an
understanding of what their function is
in
helping bring tourism back through the
pandemic
and everybody received an email um
from the director yesterday with some
information as well as some videos and
youtubes to watch to see some of the
marketing campaigns that they're
involved with
would be your opportunity to ask them
questions on
what does the
vaccination and
and other things i'm going to do to
travel and tourism
business
uh represent all me on the males and
homes
yes
thank you i just wanted to read from the
upper valley business alliance our
chamber of commerce
on
on broadside that went out yesterday to
the businesses
there is uh from the american rescue
plan
there is
uh 28.6
billion dollars being allocated to
restaurants food trucks caterers and any
place that serves prepared food or drink
to customers so coffee houses juice bars
produce wineries distillery sampling
businesses also qualify
directly administered by the small
business
administration
rather than the banks this time
dollar capped so on the people that
apply first get it so they're telling
everybody uh go get that
and they're telling them how to do it uh
there is also a shuttered venue operator
grant which is for our
our on
movie theaters and our
our on opera houses and on our ballet
troops and all the rest of it
and
that one is both allowing them to apply
to for ppp as well as for a grant
program that the small business
administration is
administering also and they're
apparently ramping up for it right now
there's some other stuff for general
businesses on quite a bit of stuff for
general businesses but this one is
specific for the rooms and mail stacks
they didn't get
much help on
the previous time because they are small
and
it was going through banks and
if you didn't have a good banking
relationship you didn't manage to get in
on the front of the queue
but um that's on i think going to be
significant in on rescuing and booting
up those of our restaurants and
ins and such that have survived up till
now
and on getting them ready for this
summer when um
[Music]
most of the people that on we would be
seeing as tourists will have been
vaccinated
by then and are raring to get out of
their houses in their immediate
environments and have been
apparently booking up very fast um
a lot of the tourist venues in new
hampshire
susan
will be
uh checks that are going out to
everybody which may send some more
locals out to eat thanks
susan does that say anything about the
federal funds that are going for small
to be distributed by the small
businesses association
i can i can send the
the emails that i got from them directly
to everybody
why don't you do that because i'm i i'm
concerned that
they may send
a greater portion of that funds to
certain types of states than other
states
or is it distributed on a per population
basis
on the restaurant revitalization fund
is dollar capped across the country so
it depends on our chambers of commerce
doing what our chamber of commerce just
did which is to send it out immediately
to all of the people and give them the
steps they need to use to start the
application before the application is
open okay all right
so if you could send that to the
committee great
uh representative offline
yeah thank you mr chairman i just wanted
to also you know reiterate that i
believe between the pent-up demand the
stimulus coming in um
for tourism that's going to enable
tourism and also you're seeing state
parks
um talk about a full and open summer and
that they're pushing for that on hampton
beach
um i think you've got the federal
government saying that they want
uh all states to have vaccinations
available to all adults by may 1st and
the governor has said that we're on
track for that so i think all things
considered i would tend to anticipate a
summer much more like
2019 than 20 20. um
and and i know that affects
you know when you look at the the tax
cut for meals and rooms that would mean
a greater loss of potential revenue
than what we see there
okay
any questions of
offline
not representative bromley
yeah the the real elephant in the room
is
is when will the state of emergency be
lifted
i'm starting to hear rumblings that it
may be sooner than we think
but i i've we've never got verification
on that
uh
maybe that's something we could try with
the governor's office uh he may not be
willing to
play that hand
uh but
uh but that is there are states that are
starting to really seriously look at
race and i think they've already done
a lifting the states of emergency in
their states
um
now that doesn't mean that when meals
and rooms and rentals
that even after that would happen that
that there'd still be people slow to
go back to our restaurant or to a
theater
uh
you know uh
but that over time i'm sure that will
that will evolve but
um
i think the timing on the raising of
this of the lifting of the state of
emergency is a important thing
so i don't know how we get the feel for
that but uh just a comment then but
maybe some of you and i missed here we
could chat about
okay uh is matt still available i mean
i don't believe so but i'll look again
okay
yeah
you only see a few people
yeah he's not there
okay
that's a good question to ask now i've
heard some rumblings of when it would be
but it's just rumblings
yeah but we said
i just sent that out
okay
representative southwest
just um
you know on the news when it listed the
states where covet was increasing new
hampshire right now is one of the top
ones probably because of the colleges
so that may impact the decision to end
the mandate um
that is based on percent so it isn't
necessarily a lot of people
but we were listed in the bad column
this morning
yeah in the schools uh our schools just
got locked out again because of the
wrestling match that happened in bedford
i believe
i've been walked out for at least a
period of time
um
okay anything else on the males and
rooms
the tobacco tax
on the tobacco tax
we had in 21 247
and uh
which is
right in between the low and the high of
the dra
and for 22 we had
244.8
which is again right between there's
uh 240.5
which is probably close to the middle of
what the dra estimates
any
questions comments on the tobacco tax
the interest in dividend tax
and again this is
we have to use the current law
and
to address
the legislation we do that in hospital
through
an interest in dividend
we came up with 128.8
which is
somewhere close to the middle of what
the dra estimates
and for 22
we estimated
136.5 which is again in the middle
the dra
and 138
which is probably close to the middle
again on fy23
questions on interest and dividends
comments
the communication
facts
is the agency does a
good job on that i don't see any
changes where close to what the agency
has
questions or comments
now the real estate transfer tax
we had 191.8
for fy21
which is on the low side
but things have changed a bit
and for 22 we had 180.3
which is somewhere in between
their estimates
and in 23
we had 168.8
which is somewhere in between
any comments questions on the real
estate
i've been trying to compare the agency's
estimates from january with these and
and this one they have put up
on
more than more than the ones you've been
talking about recently
on by some because the market just keeps
on being there
but
i just want to point that out
okay
any other represent uh south side
uh thank you just a general comment
as as usual the usual the usually the
case it does look like the first two
taxes are really the ones we're gonna
have to spend most of the time on
and those also seem to be the ones where
you know we may be able to move things
more
uh confidently upwards
yeah and we probably want to keep a
an eye on the real estate transfer tax
too yes
any other questions or comments on the
vra type
taxes how about uh okay representative
romney
yeah can we decide uh now
uh which of these
we
feel
it should be no change like for instance
communication service tax i'm going to
do that now oh okay good you yeah okay
thank you
well we're gonna
we're just gathering information today
but what i was getting at is that
um mr chair what i was getting at is if
we're going to have caucuses this
afternoon
i mean if there is there seems to be a
couple of taxes here that we
aren't worthy of discussing
uh and if we can agree right now
that we'll just stay with
where we are for it the two that i come
to mind are the communication services
tax
and the
utility property tax
we're going to take these up tomorrow
and we have caucuses
coming this afternoon all right so our
recommendation in the caucus may be
don't don't change these
right
thank you
uh how about melissa or carolyn do you
have anything else to add
while we're
considering changes to the revenues
that we have to give to the finance
committee um i would just say i think
you're spot on the taxes that are
definitely um
could be reviewed our business taxes m r
and rhett you know those are the ones
that have been the hardest to predict um
during this pandemic we do know that
meals and rentals last month performed
better than we anticipated uh so i think
there is a little bit of wiggle room
maybe towards our higher end with that
and same with business taxes as we said
um
business taxes for march so far looking
looking good again you know i always
carry out that with we do have some more
days and we have refunds and then we
have april as well
uh and and lastly rhett looks like it's
going to be
another good month
looking at today's report which i'm not
sure you have received yet
we are 33 percent of head of plan and
basically most of rat funds are in
um so that
looking at our february reign or excuse
me our march range um
would be towards the middle of the range
for rhett if that helps at all for march
i just saw something today or was it
might have been yesterday that on
sale of homes
that
just about every sale
they're
competing with each other driving the
asking price up
the buyers are
in new hampshire and that's great for us
but that isn't going to last forever
yeah i'd just like to comment on that i
i think
there are two
factors to watch one is the price which
is going up
um
and that's certainly good
in terms of our revenue but um the other
factor is supply
and um
right now it's uh as everybody knows is
it's super tight that's part of the
reason prices are going up i think in
jeffrey we've got one home for sale
it was zero homes
a few days ago
but
when price goes up often supply
expands at least that's what the theory
tells us and uh
so it's a little hard to predict there
but uh i i certainly be optimistic about
the future
uh given that the uh the demand and
everything else we've talked about about
the economy uh
today
right when the
price goes up it's usually because the
inventory is is low
and
we
really don't see that much
new construction
it's people moving people deciding okay
now we can unload this house and get a
lot of money for it and go somewhere
else
you've got that kind of phenomenon
is that going to create a
bubble like
in 2008 when the prices collapse
i don't know
nobody knows
so many things here
i mean we have to be careful what we do
make life interesting yep it sure does
um represented yearly followed by
representative elmi
yeah
zillow has a 14 increase
year over year
but only a 4.5 for the first two weeks
of the year
it looks like the price is going to go
up but not uh a great deal in addition
new home uh bills
are are way way down um
which indicates that existing home sales
is going to be the primary source so
that it looks like this is a ball but
where you are in the bubble
and
i don't know that's that's the question
as to where we are are we on the build
side or are we getting ready to bust
well on
2008 we were building
many many homes
and the price was really high
and then the bubble bust
had a lot of inventory
the values went down
the
[Music]
hudson
i sit on the hudson planning board and
new home developments there haven't been
any new home developments there has been
a development in hudson but
we'll find out about that next next week
as to
whether or not that goes through
but uh new home developments
uh we haven't had any
uh for
months
just
uh get some point
representative lane you have your hands
uh yes thank you mr chair um i used to
be on the new hampshire housing finance
authority board
and i can tell you that the demand is
really more in the quote workforce
housing or affordable housing
which is why so many housing advocates
are trying to get those new homes built
and those new units built because really
the demand is not for the higher end
homes
they sell but the demand is really at
more of the lower to moderate priced
homes the first home buyer homes and
those are the ones we need to build
it may not generate as much transfer tax
but it certainly will help solve the
housing crisis
for what all that's worth
it's extremely important
and they haven't found a way to fix that
yet
um
representative blocksman um can i make a
comment on that
uh yes represent a lot often
you know i do think when you look at the
deficit of housing supply even though
even if these were
in these homes that we need are
potentially less valuable
on their own and individually
any aggregate
there's so much demand that if we were
able to meet supply you know
be a significant
boost
to the real estate transfer tax revenue
not you know not a loss just because
they're less valuable because on the
aggregate that the demand is there the
new year's there
what would you project
say
a year from now
well
you know i know we had
the governor's priority to implement
those those
dual housing bills and they were voted
down and so i think
the projected
activity that we're hoping for is
uh now up in the air unless the senate
were to do something
so i'm not sure that we're going to be
able to create that additional housing
supply we're looking for
too bad
what's in all me
oh i was going to talk about that too
that they put that bill on the table
on
and and this does it also affects the um
our our economy and the business taxes
because
a lot of places that want to expand
cannot get housing for the people that
they're trying to in fact come in and
that is uh
the middle of the upper middle on
on
salaried people as well
as the people that are our cleaners and
our carpenters and
and uh
others but
on i don't think we've
tried to talk with the
housing board or some on the realtor's
board that whether they've got recent
data on permits
for the state as versus for our
individual towns
lebanon is
full of housing permits at this point
and and they're working their way
through the final details of lawsuits
and things
thank you
representative
uh thank you in dover um they approved
building i think it's 40 cottage style
homes and uh the builder is actually the
owner of the company where many of those
people are working
and he was having the same problem
that's been mentioned before that he
couldn't find any way for his employees
to live nearby
so this is at least a beginning he's
doing 40 of them um but it does seem
like a good um kind of compromise for
now
any further
questions or comments on any of these
taxes
any questions or comments on anything
norm yes
i uh during our five-minute break i i
did call charlie mcintyre
um and this is counter-intuitive but
using the 12 was the conservative number
uh because what happens is if
if it if
if it goes down to 10 or 8 percent it
actually
uh
goes to the
uh to the owners
then
uh
the actual number of people that play
increases the handle goes up
because moore goes back to the people
playing
so the 12
is the conservative number
and they chose that purposely to keep to
be conservative on their estimate of
revenue from historic racing
so what would the uh
actual dollar number be for
again we're we're using the conservative
oh i didn't ask that uh um
i can get that
yeah and that's what i know they
prorated it um
yes
okay because
it would not it would not go into effect
for a while it had to there's some setup
time
i'll get that for for tomorrow i'll have
that for tomorrow
i just i just say
um
that that
we we probably have to go forward we
don't have enough time but that's
certainly a subject i'd like to ex
to
um
explore
in a conversation with
charlie mcintyre
yeah i don't know when we can do that
but
however you want to do it
represent major he's coming in tomorrow
morning
oh good perfect
yeah i wasn't doing one thing
any of the agency had to have to do with
the other revenue streams that we didn't
discuss today
um
especially if we
feel that they're going to the economy
is going to change their revenues
and so
we'll be talking tomorrow
sounds good
all right
what i would suggest is that
representation
you have a practice of your members
maybe this afternoon and we'll have a
caucus of our members this afternoon
we'll discuss these revenues so mr chair
should uh uh well at least for the
republican side should we come uh
prepared
uh with a high and a low or uh our best
guess on on the on the midpoint on these
to the meeting
i would start with the high and low okay
thank you
and then
i'm planning to have the
caucus around
three o'clock if anybody hasn't
let me know
and i don't know when you're gonna have
your caucus
susan
yes and we were going to have a really
quick one at lunch which was our only
time available today
on we can't start at three it's too late
for
representative ames
but
and we need some time to think about
this
so
on i think
maybe on representative ames could you
set us up for a different time starting
at two do you think
so that everybody in our caucus will
have time to
think about
on
the numbers until two o'clock
okay
both of those numbers and these that we
discussed today yes
exactly
good okay thank you
and i suggest we just look just look at
the business taxes meals and rooms and
real estate transfer tax
as well as everything in hb2
yeah do something not break into the
middle of the day like two o'clock how
about four
i can't do it representative ames has to
leave and he is he is going to be our
our uh
group to our what do you call it zoom
host can can we just stick to the
original plan i'm sorry i've got uh you
know other
in this matter so can we just none of us
are going to have time to think about
this ahead
if we do
that we're going to be thinking about it
i'd rather go ahead with noon myself and
things too
yeah i've already made all my numbers i
did it last night
most of yesterday doing administration
but
okay uh we'll we'll
start at
12 and go till whenever we have to we'll
start at 12 30.
twelve thirty okay
oh yes
oh eight now
and people can eat their lunches while
we're talking
for the republicans it's three o'clock
okay
norm you got two hands up uh
so you'll send something out i'll
represent you
no
yes i was wondering if we could do it a
little bit earlier
um
i do have i will run up against a
conflict if we start at three
uh it depends how long it takes i mean
if
i doubt we're gonna be done in half an
hour so is it possible to start at two
yes
does anybody have a problem starting at
two
mr chair three works better for me but i
would get the sense of the rest of the
members
well has his hand up as well and
herschel no
okay uh
thank you mr chair um i think three
o'clock would also work better for me
but um again if it's a big problem for
others i can be flexible
how about 2 30.
i don't think it's going to take this
long
so yeah 2 30
2 30. can i
make a suggestion yes
um
can we can we just get on it as soon as
this one's over and get it done so that
because i have appointments this
afternoon
oh that would work for me if we could
start at one or something like that as
well
just need a few minutes to put some
thoughts together
you know
how about if we start at 1 30
that's mr chair
130 might not be it's kind of like
splitting the difference so we have to
sit around for an hour i would rather do
230 or do
do it right now but i think some people
want to collect their thoughts so if 230
works with everyone i think that
could be best
norm paul has had his hand up paul paul
i'm going to be getting my shot right
about that time but i i worked up some
of my numbers last night so i'll refine
them and i'll forward them to either you
or to pat mr chair okay thank you
then why don't
we do it at 2 30
and that's
right on the borderline of satisfying
most people
okay
i'll get the link sent out right away
and for the democrats
for the democrats i've sent out the link
already and if you can't find it
please send me an email and i'll make
sure you get it
all right then i'm going to uh
close it
okay
dick dick does that mean that we're
going to have to stop by two no
no it does not
so we're gonna start at 12 30 and i hope
we stop by two but uh who knows
but no we're not stuck on that
you